you're 14 to 21. yes it's training you
no 14 to 19.
i'm sorry 14 to 19. what's the training
looking like how hard are you training
during that time i'm doing everything
first day in the morning three in the
morning you do your uh four miles come
back here three in the morning yeah
your four miles come back and do your
body exercise and all that stuff get in
the hot tub
go to bed i might watch some fight films
i watch a lot of fight films that's why
i'm very um
acute with most of the fight oh yeah so
um
after that i go after the breakfast
go to the school
come back from school
eat my
food
then i go back to the gym at six o'clock
train come back at eight o'clock
um watch fights start all over again
i do a lot of chance i do a lot my most
of my gym work and i watch movies that's
the most part of my life which which
fight was it where you
were most excited about when you won it
was it the one where you became the
heavyweight like if you go back and say
my favorite fight when i won was this
one what was it larry holmes
larry holmes yes is that because what
ali whispered to you when uh because he
beat ali up real bad and i was on the
phone cussing new alley so i talked
earlier the day after the fighting for
homes
and because i have this young black
kitty lovely channel i want you to talk
to him and i'm crying him on the phone
he said i'm gonna be back and i'm gonna
fight homes again i'm not gonna i'm glad
when i get big i'm gonna get him for you
and he must be a kid you know who i am
the greatest of all time this and this
that and that but that's what i based my
life that's my job to get larry holmes
for ali yeah that's my whole purpose in
life
wow
was it was there a rage like when you
fought against homes was it like i'm
gonna destroy you yeah
i knew i had to
yeah because you seemed angry in that
fight yeah i had to
he's a great fighter i'm a greater
mighty little lady holmes too he's a
magnificent fighter but it was just that
thing
when i saw that he beat the [ __ ] out
early
wasn't he his training guy he used to
hit his bar
yeah he used to spark together so he
kind of knew
what uh uh he was old he was taking
drugs that made him lethargic yeah um
he should have never did it but i guess
by him doing that it would never been me
unbelievable the inspiration what how
old so you're you're you're 12 years old
you see ali
from 12 at 14 you know you're going to
be heavyweight 14 i talked ali that's
what i was going to ask you so ali he
called you because of course
one of where their friend they knew he
just
and one of the people that was with us
called
ali to talk because he wanted to talk
because about something
and first things i heard because why you
let that bum beat you like that oh i
started crying
when you became the heavyweight champion
yeah first phone call afterwards who'd
you talk to
um you remember like millie wall
because if um
i don't know what he said
and living in love with his wife
the first person first person you talked
to after you won yeah what was it like
when cuss passed away like how did you
handle when it first stopped when you
got this not good
did the focus go away that the well it
intensified oh really
yeah
when you think so i would think so but
how did you manage that rage at that
point
like when you're going to that point now
how do you manage that rage because oh
no my whole objective is your total
surrender your total domination i'm
gonna destroy you
that's the mind that's why rogan said
when he watched you you were
intimidating you you know your rage is a
very unique rage to mike well that's
their fault to be intimidated that's
their fault to be intimidated yeah
wow
what an answer to
oh my god
that's their fault to be intimidated how
do you listen i scare you for something
you worked for
wow you have to give it to him without a
struggle
without a struggle you have to give it
to him
mike your wisdom is on a whole different
level man you say some stuff that you
you're like you know you're saying like
speaking you say something it's very
simple it's just it's um
whether it's whether they feel it's
elementary isn't it
i don't know about that you've lived
with a lot of people everybody here is
gonna fight for what they love for even
they never had a fifth fight in their
life they're going to fight
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]